bene tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
nuovo sono file di soldati sudanesi a
sulla mappa di the attualmente questa
custom maps incredibile però l'episodio
buona visione siamo arrivati nella casa
dello zio
spero vestito dove ci sono esperimenti
sulla gente vediamo cioè non è
sperimentino bello peccato che piove
perché il giardino vello c'è un tizio a
non è uno stato che per farlo statue
madonna che bello ragazzi fuori
bellissimo è un po critico nelle statue
ti guardano però io rubo questo vaso ok
e
ti ho fatto dei danni in giardino fai
finta di
sentito rumori e non mi sono piaciuti
infermieri 9
questa è la stalla possa entrare a
the wooden
ho capito niente non a me
cosa ho trovato il martello di thor
ok pare comunque col martello posso
pagare questa farà immagino capitana
quanto grosso sto male va beh ma mica io
io lo terrei giusto perché magari può
servire in futuro e filati ci servirà
stato e sporco di sangue e non solo
spaccato del legno figuriamoci quanto
utile e vogliamo questo grazie comunque
tenuto il gioco con le mani sono le
provate fa niente
mi serve della mezza
in mezzo a questi rumori cribis e cioè
della bella mi fate un piacere veniamo
sempre delle celle
cuoce della benzina c'è un fucile o
thank io non lo posso prendere peccato
che mi sarebbe servito benzina
benzina a qualcuno questa radica delle
porte vero sento però non c'è
e scaccia riina sempre inutile una
benzina da qualche parte ragazzi
qualcosa che in faccia a spostare lu
camion
raccolto olio non è proprio la mensa ma
va bene
ok o portare quella scatola così da
riempio appena arrivati e fratello lo
fai la benzina automatica che figata
tipo la tesla che ti fai la ricarica in
casa è utile
però
abbastanza utile grazie vado a spostare
i camion tranquillo tranquillo o non è
proprio un camion di nuova generazione
ma fa niente picco
40 tideland del cacchio stasta maniglia
che dice ah ecco la certo è una moderna
anche le macchine di oggi si accendono
così
pensa che la patente ho imparato a
prenderla così cene senza mai insegnato
esattamente questo
beh comunque a lei ben meno ma meno male
che sono riuscito tutto a posto è fatto
8mila euro i danni lo fa niente ma va
bene buongiorno
vado siamo entrare qua fascio tutta la
finestra [ __ ]
le mie maniere di bussare comunque
ragazzi gioco carino allegro mi fa
piacere che la del samu anche a e mai
nemes valigie downgrading york pachino
house with a lanterna and high spaccato
il tuo camion ei ok si
no mi si è chiusa dietro la porta porca
[ __ ] va bene tutto bello devo solo
trovare
tantum verde active viola e il problema
basta poco
c'è un altro nudo va bene
c'è gente nuda io ringrazio devo farne
un leggero mal di testa ciò va bene no
perché quando guardo i mostri sto gioco
teoricamente
dobbiamo stare attento a non essere
scoperto sì ma non ti sei accorto che
quello lì non è proprio una persona è un
tizio nudo un po modificato
geneticamente
vediamo che succede andiamo avanti sento
catene e sentire catene in un horror non
è mai un'ottima cosa già stato nella
libreria finissima avete altre cose nel
culo che vi servono di paul olio
da ei
mastella
c'è del sangue per terra tutto ok ok va
bene va bene ok
credo che lui non vada in macelleria a
prendere il prosciutto se lo fa lui però
ma le cene senso non mi sembra del posto
anche perché non è proprio igienico
insomma troppo
ognuno magna quello che vuole vediamo se
rispondere 18 mag è comunque bello è che
allegro fa piacere che casa tua sia
curata meglio della libreria comunque a
me non c'è gente nuda non è vero anche
qua cento sono le prigioni tutto a posto
in casa tua ma si esce si va verso il
giardino ok c'è la porta
un racconto rope
no non credo che sia il mio stomaco
il jardin c'è anche il genoa che bello
cioè fa un po cagare in realtà però è
che la linea ma è un po poco allegro
piove anche dentro casa pensate però è
vera bella l'idea all'idea lagarina
perché seduto topi dr.web che fastidio
c'è un piede di porco
non che mi serve in questo momento però
l'olio si l'olio mi serve
dopo questo anche i server
di addio addio
dove vado a non sono andare io no
lettieri la bottiglia non le possono che
prendere cosa per niente faccia finita
ieri
gioca lo ha lanciato la propria testa di
minchia cioè il pisello e lo vedo a un
addio o schivando sarò fenomeno già
redazione
dio mio quanto andava veloce lo zio
cazzo 616 botti a via via via via una
volta a porca [ __ ]
no ragazzi c'è ma garanzia e che non ho
parole ma cosa sto giocando vermi cos'è
sta roba
ma va bene c'erano altre forze che ori
voluto esplorare il nonno esploriamo
perché siamo un po una situazione che
non ce lo permette come tutto questo è
il problema
ma va bene vabbè ho un piede di porco
colpire di porto possono rompere delle
cose ma non capito cosa perde contro
loc
ce l'ho ce l'ho e più di qualcuno posso
usare lo appena preso luce per una volta
che ho un oggetto porco del demonio
usiamo lo vediamo
se prima non ha funzionato si trova
adesso che mi avvicino funziona credo
vediamo
oggi è avere
aule aveva funzionato sul serio cup
incredibile che l'idea
devo accendere una candela quindi devo
accendere una candela dove sta
dove sta la statua del
dell'aquila nella mail
intanto 162mila acciarini accendiamo la
statua dell'arga nella mail volo è
questa qua almeno
statua del lago vediamo una
statua dell'aquila azione sono
porca [ __ ] c'è un tizio nudo basta
quanti ticino di questo gioco di merda
e
picchia il 3 io lo posso motivare a
giocare
guardi io benedetto me l'ha preso aveva
preso solo morto solo 8 sono state
definite finita la definì tecnica fin
qui non so molto so ma
porca [ __ ]
sono entrato nell'unico punto del
demonio dove la porta è chiusa ti prego
scavalca parecchio mio
ti prego ma magari se malconcia non ci
arriva
no ragazzi in criminosa vari stati che
vivono in futuro ce la fai a scavalcare
dai madonna un corrimano come fare non
sapeva che ancora in mano e alto mezzo
metro facciamo così l'altro e poi prova
a uscire non so come
è la
[Musica]
cazzo allora rifiuto richiudo lo
richieda
oddio adesso l'avrebbe ho capito
oggi forse l'ha persa voglio perdere the
sun questo tizio orribile già salve è il
castrati pure le corrimano non ci credo
sono uscito a fuggire non so come un
genio sono geni ragazzo fuggito e la
maniera incredibile cosa c'è qua dietro
che schifo
sollecito a fuggire non so come ragazzo
non vi saprei dire come ho fatto
incredibile lo ri chiuso dentro c'è
veramente che pro players niente dal
fantastico pro player di amnesia che
culo.ora che non sarà di digiuno che non
saprei di fare questa cosa
fabriano
c'è un bagno allargato che la cosa più
normale che ho visto finora me vale
quanto il compro romagna costa una
grandezza pure berna se la sapesse
tenere eccola qua questa è questa la can
d arresto
hanno questa esordi
non si accede anzi si piega e si apre
cosa ali si apre qualcosa no vabbè
ragazzo
vabbè vabbè gioco dell'anno e ne è
uscito nel 2010 questo giorno niente
gioco dell'anno
dieci anni di annese questa porta di
merda
bellissimo siamo nella parte un po più
krypi della casa adesso un po più
madonna l'altro è un po grosso come fa
passare inosservato questa parte della
casa cioè da fuori si vede che c'è una
parte di casa un po grossa che tenti di
nascondere il suo però vabbè passo di
qua i ragazzi non mi fai uno è caduto si
è cagato sotto pure lui va bene c'è una
bar ma è il dove dorme dracula qua posso
aprirla meglio la pro quando prima in
giro se c'è qualcosa di utile per la
minchia di tutto qua laudano lautaro e
infine risorgi
trappola
transilvania non c'è nessuno sa bene
metto io arrivederci posso mettermi io
ma si può togliere
perché tutto questa ma sempre questo
che cazzo è forse una fornace ci entrò
poi l'accento va da fuoco
hospital cellar proprio lui
c'è qualcuno che ha fruttato
morirai qui proprio come lei proprio
come chi tua madre devo andar via io mi
darete [ __ ] non so come tra
26 tutto come il frignano del bomber
culo allora aspetta
di questo gioco sono io che ti aia porca
[ __ ]
sono io che tiro scatola e la gente il
nome mi piace riesca ad allerona sto
morendo
capitano saper tosti e babe minchia
ma come ha fatto devi portare calze da
portare lavandula comunque ragazzi ve la
faccio breve semplicemente questo medico
aveva una moglie che è stata assassinata
da un suo paziente quindi si è
giustamente incazzato niente fa
esperimenti sulla gente basta questo è
per adesso e questo per un giorno che
questo il tipo là sopra si è scassato le
palle di stare là sopra se n'è andato
ottimo anche perché non so se era lo
stesso di quello che purtroppo di bijoux
però è una bella notizia dai comunque
locke peak sarebbe aprire questo
storicamente
no all hockey forlì valsa il pd niente
lo trovarono a porta che effettivamente
è chiusa e la devo semplicemente
scassinare forse qua a sinistra era la
prima porta quella che non si apriva qua
può essere vediamo orie ha allora è
avere i
giudici chiudi per l'amor di dio chiusi
perché si sa mai
bene o
continuava ad investigare qua dentro
però non c'è niente ma scusa non c'è
nulla perché io c'entro niente guarda
sto male minchia soffitta nascosta
bellissimo avrei mai mi sembra di
giocare e lo nei board sotto non ci
torniamo vediamo che c'è davanti che
bella la soffitta e anche cambiata la
musica mi fa molto piacere tutto questo
questo muro è molto fragile potrei anche
prenderlo a pedate nel culo non so posso
romperlo con qualcosa va bene martello
scatola
ok l'importante è fare progressi in poco
tempo ragazzi tipo come li fa alfa vi
spacco spacco cose a domicilio va bene
giorno credo che sei entrato in una
parte della casa un po
centrato non so se sono però va bene io
dare un'occhiata al quarter sì perché
questo qua fuori subito e una nuova
stanza main all ok va bene non di qua e
un nuovo luogo completamente che figo ti
sto cacando abbastanza però c'è una
volpe balsam ata ma quanto grossa
staccano da ragazzi tela pulisci da solo
sta a casa ti fa aiutare lo zio
ragazzi
l'addio
di
aiuto
ma possono anche salire lo possa
riaccendere di salire rimango qua
eh va beh morirò
ma sfondate pure tutta la porta ma la
sfornata tutta lo zio
[ __ ] gioca lo schivato lusso come
aiuto un genio sono stato un genio non
sono una fatta scassa roba pazzesco
pazzesco number one io me ne vado
arrivederci
e stato bello
adesso sto andando cos'è che ho trovato
meno armato non è dio è quindi ragazzi
con quello più anche l'episodio di
accordi attualmente il number two spero
che vi sia piaciuto è sempre più fino
allora veramente incredibile sarà per
pazienza ci ha messo dieci anni a far
male bella valerie sapere se volete un
altro episodio ragazzi che lo porto fate
la nostra brevemente di commenti
iscrivetevi al canale lasciato un bel mi
piace e non come sempre ci vediamo hanno
proseguito i ragazzi
[Musica]